so I'm live tweeting the don't spoil the
end game ban has officially lifted and
the cast and crew are sharing all their
behind-the-scenes spoiler footage that
they definitely illegally obtained from
the set of Avengers endgame what are you
gonna do fire Chris Evans of course not
let's go through some of my favorites I
swear nothing in cinematic history will
top the first time seeing those portals
open and every single living avenger
stepping into a single scene Avengers
Assemble verse Thanos and behind the
scenes it was so cool to see some of
this footage probably the most amount of
director's chairs ever assembled on a
set and Chris Evans captured this video
of all the actors Mark Ruffalo doing
something Paul Rudd stealing the scene
Jeremy Renner dancing with a sword
Tessa lapping with Evangeline Lilly what
do we think they're talking about
speaking of the ladies our DJ snapped
this picture of all the Marvel women at
lunch I got to say this made me love the
all women Marvel moment even more and
speaking of lunch our DJ threw a fiesta
for the cast
he also shared one of the sweetest
moments of the entire freakin movie Tony
Stark's reunion with Peter Parker
dr. strangers are when I got that right
and he gave us this big birthday one
hour and the moment he did the fatal
snap ouch okay let's stop crying
Chris Hemsworth is here to cheer us up
at that scene on the lake
I like the half bearded look Chris it's
nice of course the vendors endgame is
the culmination of 22 films over a
decade at the MCU and that all started
with Iron Man 1 in 2008 whose 10-year
anniversary was celebrated on set happy
birthday to the first Ironman what was
your favorite moment behind the scenes
of Avengers end game let us know I'm ash
Crossin and I'll see you later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]